alcohol is a great social lubricant  right it's great for  releasing inhibitions and  letting people communicate with each  other more freely and have fun  but  this it's also  it removes doubt  and that's not good right i think doubt  is critical yeah like doubt is one of  the pieces of the great puzzle right the  the great puzzle has many ingredients  and one of those ingredients is doubt  and doubt is important you should look  at anything you're about to contemplate  and go hmm let me think about this let  me think what could go wrong when you  get a couple of drinks get let's do it  let's go  and then next thing you know you know  you're on an internet meme